[Music]
coming up we're going to talk about what
do you do if your boss tells you you got
to get the vaccine to keep your job we
also talked to a wife whose husband is
just not engaged and we talked to a dad
whose daughter is struggling and he
doesn't know what to do next stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up what's up this is john with
the dr john deloney show
one of the top 1000 greatest podcasts
ever made are we in the top thousand you
think of all time james absolutely i
think so
top thousand surely we can crack the top
thousand
i'll pull the numbers and let you know
he's like look at him like there's no
chance for top thousand no chance
maybe
top eleven thousand in the mental health
in middle tennessee in the afternoon
slot booyah
oh we're in the afternoon now yeah
there's no such thing as thanks for
ruining the illusion for our podcast
listeners
it's like 4 30 a.m they're starting
their morning routine they're starting
off with a good dose of relational
mental health help and then you're like
ruining it
it's cool man
how are you you good
i was going to go into a rant about how
time is actually
an illusion and it's not it's just i've
been reading a book called solve for
happy by mogadot it's a chapter on time
that was
i don't have my mind blown a lot mind
blown it's all good though hey welcome
to dr john dolone's show top 11 000
podcasts ever created we're up there
somewhere so glad you're here mental
health relationships all of it we're so
glad you're with us if you want to be on
this show give us a call
eight four four 1-844-693-3291 nine
three three two nine one or go to
johndaloni.com
ask
ask
johnalone.com
ask fill out the form and send it to
kelly
real quick a couple of shows ago
i asked people to write me a poem and
mail it to me
number one whoa i got a lot of poems in
number two some of you
need to go to betterhelp.com
because you're not okay you're just
you're just you're not okay things
aren't good in your heart
um and they are coming out in your poems
some of you are hilarious and awesome
and so i'm gonna do a segment in a
couple of shows reading some of these
but
a bajillion of you do not know this it's
incredible new tool i know it's new and
so some of y'all don't know what it is
or how it works
um it's this it's bizarre if it's a new
computer technology called the googles
and you go to google.com and put in
ramsey solution address because some of
you can't do that you emailed kelly
i think the total is 17 million and six
of you emailed kelly and said hey what's
the address to ramsey solutions
so for those of you who are
jogging right now listening to this
podcast but you happen to have a pen and
paper on you it's 1011 reams fleming
boulevard
franklin tennessee 37064.
r-e-a-m-s hyphen
because we're um progressive in that way
rheem's fleming reams hyphen there's no
hyphen there's not no
i was trying to hyphenate it
there we go i think it'll find its way
here anyway it'll find its way franklin
tennessee 37064.
i feel like this is a tv show from the
early 90s where you you read the p.o box
address to mail postcard at the end of
the nickelodeon show yes
mcgruff scruff mcgruff chicago illinois
60652
whoa
and by the way uh on the boards today is
good will hunting who knows all the
numbers from his childhood way to go
nick that's incredible so um keep
sending your poems we're gonna have a
poetry themed show i guess they're
incredible some people are sending them
and some of you who need uh mental
health help you know who you are all
right so before we take a call today
this emails i've been given getting this
email a lot so i want to address this
right out of the gate
um here's one my wife and i had our
third baby in march and
she's still breastfeeding she just got
noticed that her work is mandating the
vaccine and she has to let them know by
the end of august if she's getting it or
not and then has to be vaccinated
vaccinated by the end of september if
not she'll lose her job next one is
somebody who's working for
you know federal state local government
that they are forcing them to get the
vaccine
they're subjected to constant testing
constant masking where do i draw the
line that says enough is enough and take
another job
i don't want to i want to walk out i'm
married with debt and a mortgage so
and this is two of a bajillion of these
right
lots of concern my buddy ken coleman
he's getting him on his show he talks
about career lots of people calling in
writing in asking
we are working somewhere where the
vaccination is being mandated
and we don't
we're not anti-vaxxers not
anti-covariance
we all the sudden are alarm bells about
hey you're you're not free or ringing
we're scared and we don't know what to
do what should we do what should we do
so anytime i'm faced with a situation
like this so i'm going to take kovad out
of the equation we're going to move it
over here i can't solve that question
for you i can answer that question for
you that's between you and your doctor
and your personal conscience and all
those things i've talked about my
opinions on that on this show
what i can
drill down here is
what you can control and what you can't
and at the end of the day any decision
and that's i'm intentional about my
language there any decision any time you
choose to worry get angry fight claw go
to war against something that you can't
control
you are choosing to have misery now
there are justice moments in history no
question about it there are moments you
head to the streets i get that i support
that i love that about this country i
love it
i love it there are moments you write a
letter there are moments you go knock on
somebody's door there are moments you
say enough's enough and i get that
totally get that
but if you work for somebody
and they tell you as a
condition of working here you have to
tuck your shirt in i've had that told to
me before
i've been called in an office by two
professional
um
uh
two professional employees that said
we're gonna come check on what you were
wearing
and we're gonna come by and see because
we don't think you'd dress professional
we think you should dress perfect more
professional and so we're gonna come
check on you
i've had people tell them you gotta i
gotta cut my hair
i've had people tell me that these shoes
aren't good you need to wear those shoes
this is all across the span of my career
um
hey you've gotta tuck your shirt in it's
been the most i don't like talking my
shirt and it makes me feel weird
and i've had that over and over and
here's the deal
every time that's happened
i've been working for somebody else
and it's their place where they work
and so i've got the option
of
deciding am i gonna tuck my shirt in or
am i am i gonna get another job
in some seasons in my life like one of
these um emails here i owed a whole
bunch of money in student loans
i didn't have another choice
i was frozen i'd created a life for
myself where i i was out of control i
couldn't control tomorrow because
i had a bunch of um strings attached to
everything right
now if dave came in and said you have to
do this
i'm in a situation where i would smile
at him and say i'm i'm not gonna
dave's always trying to get me to wear
pink shoes and he's not really but if he
did and i said no i wear black shoes i
have to be a weird line to draw but
whatever
um
now anybody any money i would leave
right i would leave
so whether it's the vaccine whether it's
where you're going to cut your hair
whether it's um you have to be on call
24 7 365. i was a finalist for one job
that said you have to live within 10
miles of the organization it was a
university and they said you've got to
live this close because if something
happens in the middle of the night you
got to be able to get here
and when i was looking for houses the
houses i found were 15 or 20 minutes
away not 10 10 minutes away
all that to say is this
drill down your options into what can
you control and what do you what can
what you can you not control
if you really believe
this is an infringement on your rights
which it might be if you really believe
if i put this vaccine in my body i'm
going to get sick i'm going to i'm
feeling the blame
and you think i can't work here anymore
then quit
if you're mad that somebody's telling
you what to do
and you're frustrated they're telling
you what to do but you're gonna get the
vaccine anyway
exhale
write it down and say this sucks and i'm
annoyed by it and then let it go
because talking about it texting about
it emailing about it raging about it
scrolling on instagram it's going to
make you nuts
and right now the vaccine the co all the
stuff is pulsing through people's veins
so i want to back out as far as we can
and say this has been happening to all
of us in all of our jobs
for a long long time probably forever
unless you have a business that you are
the sole owner of and even then you're
subjected to county codes
and local ordinances and federal
ordinances and whatever
all of us do things every day that we
probably wouldn't otherwise do
if we didn't have people telling us what
to do
this is just a long line it is different
because you're asking students to put
something in our body and i will say
that's different i get that that just
feels more invasive is that fair james
that this one feels more invasive
yeah that's just a hot button issue i i
i feel like i'm minimizing at the same
time i am kind of minimizing it
um
it's the same principle but yeah i mean
putting injecting something in your body
and protecting your shirt and are not
the same thing but the principal can
principle the same my my boss is saying
you have to do this if you want to work
here cool i do get that it's a little
bit bigger deal it's a lot bigger deal
um putting something in your body and
plus
what if it has secret metal in it and
they're going to track you what all this
i don't know what all that kind of
conspiracy stuff
but at the end of the day
the question to be asked is are you
going to do this or are you not and if
you're not i refuse to do it then you've
made your decision be at peace with your
decision
and then
immediately start looking for where
you're going to go next what are you
going to do where are you going to work
what are you going to what situation
you're going to put yourself in where
this isn't going to happen again or if
you're going to do it
exhale choose not to carry anger and
rage and frustration and pissed off
don't carry that with you because you're
choosing to poison your relationship
with your spouse with your friends with
your kids
over
anger even if it's righteous anger if
you're gonna do it anyway just don't
just get it done and then move on with
your life
i don't for one bit
not for one bit i've left two jobs in my
life because i said y'all are asking me
to do something that i can't do i've
done it twice and it was hard it was
messy and
it was hard
it was hard but it it was one of my
lines and so i've been there if this is
your line man high five them make them
be respectful treat everyone with
dignity walk out with your head held
high
give notice be a good person in this
transition
retain your dignity even when those
around you are not
and
control what you can control let the
rest go
is that fair james i don't know
i don't want to minimize it kelly's i
mean
i don't want to under dramatize it but
no i think that's the gist of it as a
private you know as a
a company has the right if you don't
want to work there you have the right
not to work there yeah so it's just a
decision you have to make yeah but like
you said just make the decision and then
move on yeah
just just going to rage just yeah yeah
and don't gripe about it with all your
co-workers over and over and over and
over and over and create dissension
where you work yeah just make your
personal decision stand tall be a person
to character wherever you land and then
walk away so that's my thoughts on that
i don't know it's hard you know it's
messy and people being feel like they're
being forced into uh backed into a
corner some of you are and i get that
when it comes to man medical issues
we're breastfeeding now and we're being
forced to do this that's really tough
that is really tough right um because
you're talking about some major unknowns
there and i absolutely get that
come to some piece about a decision make
your decision and then
put the other stuff down okay and if
nothing else let this stand as a
reminder
the fewer tethers you have
like debt
like
unhealthy relationships like
um bad unhealthy habits
if you are
actively creating a life
that is healthy that is safe that you
are in control of more things than you
are not if you don't owe anybody any
money when these moments come up
you know it's like dave ramsey says
about have an emergency fund
you get your car engine can blow up and
if you have a six-month emergency fund
it's annoying you're like ugh i don't
want to go buy a car
or if you don't have an emergency fund
and you got six figures of student loan
debt it's a tragedy
i don't know how i'm gonna eat right
same issue just two different responses
and so
live a life work hard to have people in
your life that when tough things come up
you can sit down and walk through it
with have someone to walk through it
with you
build a life where you don't owe anybody
any money work hard to get there work
hard hard hard right read new books
um
exercise eat right sleep have good
relationships i'm just gonna keep
talking over and over this is one of
those moments that we all go oh
this is why this is why right
all right that's enough of that let's go
to melissa in salt lake city hey melissa
what's going on
hi john how are you i'm fantastic how
about you
i'm doing well thank you awesome so
what's up how can i help
so
i would love to ask you a question and
then i'd love to give you a little bit
of context so cool do me a favor talk
talk right into the phone and make sure
i don't miss this right
right in the phone is that better
perfect yes
okay
i am dealing with some feelings of
how do i help with these feelings like i
am the thriving force
behind my marriage and my family
so i have a wonderful husband he is a
great dad he provides for our family
pitches in
um he's had a fairly smooth life and
it's been pretty mapped out for him and
he's just kind of checked things off
um
when it comes to goals when it comes to
building relationships when it comes to
personal and improvement these are not
things that cross his mind
and
i feel like especially when it comes to
wanting my kids to have
strong healthy relationships with him
i feel like i'm the one that's bleeding
i'm directing i'm pushing it turns into
what feels like nagging
feels like not having a teeth and
i just
i get exhausted of the feeling of
feeling like i have to take care of
everyone and everything
i don't i want to have i don't want to
feel like i'm fooling relationships
because that
inaudib
um
i i guess the best way for me to
describe it is that he's the boat
and he's just cruising along through
life on the water and i am the propeller
and i am spinning like crazy
to get forward momentum
and
it's just unseen so
i i
would love your thoughts and opinions
but i also feel a little bit
silly
calling asking about this because he is
such a wonderful man and he's
when i've listened to your show before
and the crisis that people have in their
lives it just makes me feel a little
i don't know bashful i guess
i don't think that at all i i'm grateful
that yeah i'm grateful that you called
um
everybody's got holes in their boat
to use your analogy some of them are
huge
some of them are small
but the boat is filling up with water
yeah and
sometimes when there's a giant hole in
the boat it's actually better because
you got to deal with it right now
what you're describing is the birthplace
of resentment and you've heard me say
over and over that's the end of
everything
or more importantly
um or more negatively however whatever
word you want to use
this is how you run into somebody at
work and they're a super go-getter
and they're kind of funny
and
they
laugh when you make a joke and you all
go ahead and grab lunch together and
suddenly two years down the road you
find yourself in a position like oh no
right yeah that's where this starts
right here great guy awesome
show wouldn't even occur to him to cheat
on anybody it's not gonna hurt him to do
anything because he's just doing what he
does right yeah and am i on the am i
am on the right track
yes abs yeah okay so
um
how long have you all been married
13 years
see you're right there okay
how many how old are your kids
the oldest is eleven the youngest two we
have four of them
eleven to two
uh-huh so you've been pregnant for a
decade
yeah exactly yes i've had a decade of
pregnancy and childbirth exactly wow
okay
um
and no more
season foreign passed
[Laughter]
four no more ours was two and i'm done
with you james uh you're four no more
two
um
have you have you sat down and told him
this stuff
i have many times talk to me about what
that's like
let me back it up let's don't even do
that question yet where do you want to
go
where do i want to go because here's
what i here's what i'm afraid is
happening
and
i've got no context for this call i'm
just i've heard your voice a thousand
times
and tell you say dylan you're wrong
you're crazy on this one okay
he's his life is exactly how he drew it
up he has an incredible wife he's got
four healthy wonderful kids he's got an
11 year old a two-year-old and everyone
in between he's got a job he goes to and
he comes home the house is there things
are just rocking and rolling
my fear is you just want to go for the
sake of going
and you don't even know where you just
want to go
and it's that pent-up energy that's
going to get everybody in trouble
because it's got it's not directed
anywhere does that make sense
yeah
so are you just feeling this this
13-year same guy you got four kids and
you're missing romance and excitement in
the mystery in the ah
is that what it is
there's definitely ahead of that
okay so what else is it
yeah i think it's also just feeling like
i
i i see improvements i can make in
myself
and i see improvements and i i see
things that i
value i value having
um
and putting in the effort
to have that kind of relationship and to
and to practice what i preach i like to
uh steer the plenty of it hey you're um
your phone call your phone's breaking up
can you go to a place this is super
important can you place we get good
signal all right no you're good
is that okay great perfect much much
better
okay i guess i'm just kind of
there is a little bit of like this
stagnant i guess that i can feel of just
like okay i just need something i just
need a little spark i need just a little
something but then there's also the
feeling of i have these values that i
try to show in my actions of valuing my
kids and valuing
personal improvement through my health
and through you know physical activities
and
putting in effort and i value
having a relationship with him and the
effort feels so one-sided
okay is this covert for he's gained a
lot of weight you're not attracted to
him anymore
oh no absolutely not okay if anything
i've done that
so
what what is
get to the root like there's something
you're you're so kind
and you're so diplomatic get to the root
oh gosh
have you ever cheated on him
no
never are you thinking about it
no are you bored to death
no
are you scared about tomorrow what i
mean where what what is it
i think it's just feeling like i'm the
only one that's putting any effort in
this relationship
it's feeling like what's the effort
towards
because i keep hearing conversations
about energy
yeah
the effort is probably towards
him having a relationship with me
feeling like i have to be the one that
instigates everything i have to
instigate like hey it's been a while
since we've been on a date or hey it's
been a while since you've had one-on-one
time with each of the kids and hey maybe
we should like plan a family trip to
spend time with each other and hey maybe
we should
spend less time on our phone so that our
kids can see our eyes when we're around
them and
hey let's maybe and it's just like this
constant initiation that i have to put
forth
where i almost feel like this i don't
know if it's discontent or if it's just
this drive to
improve no you're dealing with it
listen melissa that's what i was looking
for
i your whole go when you listen to this
call go back and listen
that's the voice i was looking for
that's the voice of a woman who's
married to a depressed man
a man who's checked out
a man who doesn't feel like he's got a
purpose in his own house
yeah he's got no mission in his house
he's got a wife that runs everything
that tells everybody where they need to
be the picture
are y'all a family that gets like family
photos
uh every once in a while yeah even when
we have a new kid
see
and do you tell everyone where they're
going to stand
um
yeah yeah you do tell everybody what
they're going to wear and exactly right
yeah yeah
so what you are doing is you have a very
clear picture of what family is what
life is what husband looks like what
kids are going to look like how they're
going to talk how they're going to act
how much sex we're going to have what
our bodies are going to look like you've
got very clear pictures
yeah and for 13 years plus however many
years you dated this guy
you've just been the picture person
yeah
and he hasn't for
a decade and a half now
he's just going along with your photo
yeah
and over time he's checked out
completely
yeah he's out and so
he's getting his needs met through a
phone or through his work relationships
or through his girlfriend and i'm being
provocative if you're on purpose i'm not
saying you cheat on you but yeah he's
getting his needs met somewhere else
because the needs at his home are being
met by you
right and then the only way you think
you can rattle the cage
is complaining nagging blaming
threatening right
these
these things that you feel like you're
rattling the cage and all they do to
somebody who's checked out is it further
reinforces they made the right decision
to be unplugged
and the difference being what is caring
and listening and contributing support
what is that what does that look like
and so you said you've talked to him a
lot about it
put me in the seat you guys are out on a
marriage retreat just you two y'all took
one together
and you sit down with him and don't say
hey
i need somebody who's gonna do this i
want this i want this if you ask him
how's your life
do you still like me do you like her
kids
what would his answer to those questions
be
it would be yes but
he probably would have never thought
about it before i asked
and so what he needs to know is that
that's an expectation i need you to
think about these things
does he know that
yeah that's the perpetual argument we
have
and how is that an argument
like so for instance here's what i'm
getting at i was able i'm able to go to
bed with their dishes in the sink i just
am it's a spiritual gift whatever i can
just go to bed
uh my wife cannot right they need to be
the
place needs to be and i could walk past
them
and it wasn't until she was able to say
i need you to come see this this weighs
on my heart that i went oh gosh well
then i can just help with that like does
that make sense it was i just wasn't
seeing it
now that you have said this matters to
me and should you have to tell a dad to
put his phone down no but that's the
world war so you did that right
yeah
he's checked out and so when you say i
need you to plug back in i need your
phone to go in a drawer because right
now your kids believe you love that
little digital box more than them what
does he say
it happens he's willing
and it just doesn't last
have you told him
here is my here is my either or
statement
either you put your phone away and
connect with your kids or
i'm gonna take them to mother and
father's house we're gonna get out of
here
have you done that
no because you keep telling me he's a
great wonderful awesome wonderful guy
and then you told me the things he's not
involved with and that doesn't say great
and awesome and wonderful
right
if you mean great and awesome and
wonderful because he's peaceful and
doesn't hit anybody who doesn't yell at
anybody
that's that's the basics you're not
supposed to hit or yell or scream
right
yeah that doesn't make you wonderful
that's baseline
wait
why won't he engage yeah why is he
scared of you is he annoyed by you is he
not attracted to you what's the deal
i think you know what is it i think i
think it's just because it's easier
it's easier just to
let me take care of everything
do you let him take care of things
letting me take care of him i know but
do you let him
do you let him choose vacations do you
let him choose dinner places when you
say i want to get photos taken we're all
going to wear our white little sailor
outfits and he says can we just wear a
regular clothes do you go that's cool or
do you say no this is what we're wearing
if he put the effort into thinking about
a vacation
and to thinking about dinner places i
asked yes i would let him why doesn't he
date his wife anymore that's my question
because it takes effort it can't it
can't be that because he had a lot of
effort when he chased you down is that
right
no
okay then so now you're mad that he's
six foot tall and you married a six foot
tall guy
yeah
like it sounds like he didn't trick you
no
it sounds like you hoped this would just
quote unquote work itself out
or somehow by osmosis he would just
transform into the into the guy that you
so badly want him to be
i just
yeah
probably
i think i think before just it was just
easier it was easier you know i could go
on for
six five six seven years and and be okay
taking care of everything and then
probably the last two years just kind of
whacked me over the head with a bat and
all of a sudden it was like i don't have
it anymore
to take care of everything
anymore yeah and so
i need to feel like i'm not i'm the only
one
i need to feel like i'm not the only one
putting in the effort i'm not the only
one that cares about what the
relationships with our kids looks like
i'm not the only one that cares about
the relationship in our marriage and
what it looks like so i'm gonna break
your heart melissa okay
damn kid don't do that no i'm just
kidding go ahead
it's not going to change
yeah
it's not
yeah
this is who you married and you've done
that for 15 years now do i think he
could change oh my gosh absolutely he
could
yeah absolutely good
but your conversations you're you're
nagging you're threatening
you're
um complaining it's not it's not doing
anything
and so i think we're at a moment now in
your family's history where you've got
to decide what's the next move for you
have you gone to see somebody by
yourself just to talk through this
yes i've been seeing somebody for
postpartum depression for the last year
or so and this has come up and we have
discussed this yes and what did they say
to do
a little bit of the same thing of of
you can't
you can't control the relationships that
he has with the kids
that's not your place
you know it's this you just can't i
can't control because if i
force relationships or if i force it the
kids would
potentially get old enough and will say
well that dad didn't really want to that
was mom forcing him well and beyond that
you're going to be exhausted and
heartbroken the whole the whole time
right because none of it will be real
yeah
right so here's what i want you to do
at the end of the day it's the old
dr henry cloud quote that i love which
is he's gonna have to get some problems
and he doesn't have any
there is no reason in his life other
than integrity and character which he
doesn't have
to get involved with this kid's life
to do the hard crazy work of
having four kids in 10 years and
rediscovering who his wife is re-dating
her
deciding i'm gonna level into this
family support this family not just
financially but
emotionally psychologically spiritual
all those things right i'm gonna be
connected in this thing
he's gonna have to get some problems and
he's never had him he's never had to he
doesn't even know what that is
i want you to get a book by dr henry
cloud called necessary endings
okay
and i'm not telling you to end your
marriage in any way shape form or
fashion
yeah i'm telling you you are making
yourself clinically insane by trying to
close the gap
that has always been there yeah does
that make sense
absolutely and at the end of the day
your choices are i'm gonna love
this i'm gonna love those kids like
they've never been loved before ever
and i'm not gonna i can't get into his
i'm gonna have to accept how he's chosen
to parent
or
you're gonna have to go do something
else
yeah does that make sense
yep but just yelling into the grand
canyon isn't solving that problem
there's either acceptance of it
and you have to work for the rest of
your
kids lives to not fall into resentment
or you're gonna have to sit down with
your husband and say here's my or what
statement you're going to get involved
you're going to put the phone away
you're going to we're going to learn how
to love each other again we're going to
start practicing desire we're going to
go to marriage retreats we're going to
go to marriage counseling we're going to
go back and
remember what's like to love each other
and i'm not carrying the weight of this
family anymore
we are going to carry the weight of this
family and i'm asking you to learn a
whole new skill set
and i've seen it happen over and over
and over again i know he can
if he wants to here's where this sucks
though
is it's a risk because he might look at
you and say no
yeah right and in fact in many ways he
has right
yeah because you've asked him over and
over and over and over
is that fair
yep
no i totally get it sorry you hit the
nail on the head when you talk about
being connected not just financially
because we've had that conversation of
you are more than a paycheck that puts a
roof over our head
and and and
you've got to ask yourself have i
treated him like anything other than a
paycheck
does his opinions matter in this house
and so maybe you all go out and you have
a retreat and say i'm looking down the
road we have a two-year-old and 11 year
old we've got eight years left
for our oldest one to be here at our
home we have 16 years left for our
youngest one to be in our home
i want to we're done now for we're for
and out
i want to build what i want to sit down
and map out what the next 10 years is
going to be and i'm done driving
i've driven for 15 years i'm out i'm not
driving anymore i'm handing you the keys
and here's what that looks like in my
head i want to hear what it looks like
in your head in my head it looks like no
phones in my head it looks like
um
you and i go on dates every single week
so our kids can look like we can have a
picture of what romance actually looks
like
we're gonna hug and we're gonna kiss
every morning and at night ooh
in front of the kids so they see what
that looks like
we're gonna argue and fall back in love
we're gonna have two vacations a year
and you're gonna plan one of them alone
and we're gonna go
and so on
you need to be very clear with what you
are expecting the driver of this car to
look like
but he needs to know that have it very
clear and you tell him i will support
you i will love you i will go to these
things with you you learn these new
schools but i'm going to be involved
with you
but we have to build this thing up from
the floor up
and all of this all of this melissa is a
risk
because he may just say no
[Music]
but you deserve it your kids deserve it
thanks for that call i want to know how
that conversation that breakfast you'll
take that half day retreat you take on a
saturday i want to know what that's like
give us a call back and let me know how
that goes and by the way if he wants to
call the show i would love love love to
talk to that too i'd love to all right
thank you so much for the call hey we'll
be right back on the dr john daloni show
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important your
mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy for you video
chat phone or even text chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you become a better version of
yourself help you get on the road to
being well go to betterhelp.com10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy and
you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right we're back let's go to brad in
cincinnati hey brad what's going on man
hey doc i appreciate your time thanks
thanks brother thanks for calling what's
up
yes well sir i need your help
with uh being able to persuade my
daughter to agree to continue her
treatment for ocd
whoo
so that is my original clinical
diagnosis ocd
so yeah um
i have been on both sides of this what
um
she have behaviors she have uh thoughts
what what's what's your struggle with
it's most yeah mostly rumination okay
nation not so much physical so
my wife and i don't even i think don't
even have a full
understanding of all the things she
deals with because i don't even i'm not
even sure she's led us all the way in
sure that because she's got this as a
secret from everybody okay as well and
so she's been to some counselors i'm
like you know relatively short we've
done supplements
we've uh i've even
done neurofeedback for a while we've had
some some uh you know some small uh
improvements but overall uh her attitude
is i just want it going on i shouldn't
have to have treatment you know this is
not fair
i don't i don't want this i just want to
be gone i don't i don't want to say i
don't want to ever think that i had to
go get help you know i don't want to
have to go treatment on it the last
counselor was an ocd specialist who
recommended
she considered medications
and uh
you know there have been a couple times
when she momentarily agreed to to to
take that next step but but she won't do
it she won't do it how old is she
uh she's just 17 should be 18 real soon
okay
um
i'd love to talk to her if she ever
wants to call in if y'all want to call
in together i don't know if she'll ever
do that but i'd love to talk to her
um
been there
um
so for those who don't like i know ocd
gets a gets there's like it's in the
movies and it looks like just somebody's
washing their hands a lot like that
think of i consider ocd a part of the
anxiety
family and compulsive thoughts are
compulsive behaviors right whether it's
washing your hands or cleaning one of
mine is locking doors um i just know i
take two laps around the house every
night every single night when i'm in a
hotel i take two laps around the hotel
my family knows it i know it i don't
fight it i laugh about it sometimes i'll
just smile about it but um accounting i
get stuck counting corners sometimes
it's just a thing right
um i went to war over it for years
and part of me
being able to just have a great life was
making peace with it right and then some
of the ones that were a little more
challenging like the
catastrophizing thoughts um i did work
hard on those and now i just don't have
them anymore or when they start to spin
up i've got a couple of things i can do
between them
um for those who don't know
i can't describe the urge in a way that
makes
people who don't struggle with ocd
understand it
other than maybe don't eat for 24 hours
and then walk into a room and there's
that smell of pizza
and you have to grab a piece or you've
maybe you've run a couple of miles in
the heat and you have to have a drink of
water
it's a it's it's an urge it's bizarre
it's so powerful right and uh people
with addiction struggle with it so when
what what thoughts are spinning in her
head is she suicidal is she having
catastrophizing thoughts are she scared
of the future what is she what's she
spinning around with
well it started out with catastrophe
and that kind of thing you know mom and
dad dying that kind of stuff but it's
kind of moved on to a lot of things i
mean she uh
she's even struggling with eating now
yeah she has a lot of thoughts of
you know items being morally dirty you
know if she had to talk about something
that she didn't particularly like and
she was near a piece of furniture well
now that piece of furniture is dirty or
now that room in the house is dirty
right
so it's it's
you know she's it's bleeding into a lot
of different things you know the
relationships are being more difficult
especially with me and uh
she's got anger issues she's got a
win-lose mindset uh kind of thing you
know we try to give her good ideas to
try to help her and bless her and then
she will actually say well i can't do
that now because that's what you
recommended so i'm not going to do that
you know that kind of thing and
uh some of that some of that
is is she's 17
right right well i know i thought that
but i can't tell you know where that
line is right and uh so it makes it hard
and i'm so frustrated and and
heartbroken because i worry so much
about where this could lead
you know if
if she doesn't get um help and and so
you know as a dad i'm like oh honey
please you know let's let's talk about
this so i probably you know i'm kind of
trying to be upfront and a
non-threatening way to say honey you
know just trying to point out things in
the logic and that just doesn't work
there you go that's right
and you're right and so
when that doesn't work i'm like oh okay
what do i do you know how do i how do i
talk you know i mean we can't even
really have a calm conversation like you
and i are now you know so
so it's extremely difficult um i'm gonna
ask you a question it's gonna sound like
i'm accusing you of something please
please don't hear that okay i'm just
trying to get one more piece of
information and then we can get we can
get on down the road okay
right
walk me through
her childhood
was there
where did this stuff emerge from was
there were was there chaos growing up
was there frustration was there anger
does she have trauma in her past
yeah well
great question and i anticipate that
question
um and uh i don't think so i think she
would tell you you know that she had
pretty good childhood up until a point
uh when her older sister left for
college there you go that's when that's
when everything that's when she
pretty much identified her life as being
destroyed and over okay
and how long ago was that
that was five years ago okay
and since then it's just been spinning
and spinning and then all of a sudden
it's yeah yeah okay at first you know it
was just
you know putting two and two together in
her mind that just didn't make sense and
we spent hours talking
you know it's not gonna be that bad it's
gonna be fine you know and it's just it
never
you know it's just like bouncing off of
her you know and she's just never put it
together and then it's just kind of
grown and grown and and so as i see this
thing just building this impenetrable
defense to protect itself it just gets
me more and more concerned and right
so here
a couple of things here okay
and i want you there's i'm going to give
you a couple things you can do starting
today
all right starting right when this thing
is over
um
she may say no she's a 17 year old
right i mean she's a 17 year old woman
she can say no
but she's also a 17 year old kid okay
and mom's got to be on board too all
right right whenever
somebody's struggling
with anxiety or more than that
somebody is
mourning a relationship that meant
everything that got plucked out of the
moon
or when a kid wants so badly to go to
chuck e cheese and all of a sudden chuck
e cheese is closed and they get a little
bit agitated and i turn around and as
dad and say
it's not that big a deal when you chill
out
what i've just done
is i've given them information that is
contrary to what their body is telling
them
and for a child it makes them feel
insane
so when a i hit i spank if i spank my
kid all right let's say you spank your
child and you say that didn't hurt
their body says that hurts
and their heart says my dad hit me that
hurts and their mind says i'm
heartbroken
but also this guy who's smart is telling
me it doesn't hurt and then the
it just goes
the machine the their brain does right
so
go back five years ago
the one thing that mattered to your
daughter for probably a thousand
different reasons was her older sister
a person who was safe for her
she could laugh with could be honest
with and whatever honest means for a 12
year old right
um right and then all of a sudden that
got unplugged
and that wasn't a
cognitive issue that is not an
information issue that is the
fight or flight the hey your tribe just
left you part of her brain that sounded
every alarm she had
and then the folks who love her man
y'all came in to help and you
i mean like hey it's gonna you're gonna
be fine it's not even that big a deal
and her body is saying help and her head
saying i guess it's not that big a deal
and now you got a fracture does that
make sense you see where i'm going with
that
yeah i do i do and so what we've tried
to do over the last four or five years
is solve a connection issue with info
and now the the relationship itself has
become a um
an anxious interaction right yes yes and
these four hour f uh conversations that
feel like you're spinning in circles and
then one night you go to bed you're like
i think i finally got through i gave her
the right analogy or the right metaphor
the right whatever
and she lays down and her brain's off to
the races again because the thing it's
trying to solve for is safe relationship
not info
yeah that's right and we want to do that
no i know you i know you do i i know you
do listen
so how do we do that so brad can i tell
you this can i tell you
sure you're a great dad and you love
your daughter
okay
i do and and i don't want you to hang up
being like well crap i screwed this up
i'm not telling you that what i'm
telling you is
i think moving this way
going west taking a right
there's some things you can do different
so here's what we're gonna solve for
we're going to solve for a relationship
we're going to solve for safety
okay now
i if you've listened to this show i'm
not a throw medicine at something first
there is a moment when your anxiety
alarms
you've been in a hotel before that gets
the the fire alarm gets set off because
there's too much uh you get hot water in
there right and it's steam set it off
that is that's an alarm that's busted
it's sensitive it's too sensitive needs
to be recalibrated um
there is a season when
low-dose medication for this is good
because it turns the alarms off so that
you can finally start having these
conversations does that make sense
perfect sense um and so if your doctor
has said hey we're in you're five
and these things aren't working and now
your daughter's telling you i can't even
go into the things that are gonna help
me to have help because they are setting
the that tells me that you may have
again i'm not a medical doctor but you
may have an alarm system that's just
needs to be recalibrated and reset
okay
so i wouldn't say you're a failure i
wouldn't say anything's broken i'd say
that's a gr like just get in there and
get done with it okay
the second thing is
is
this is gonna sound so cheesy and so
lame
so cheesy and so lame you're gonna say
dude we've spent thousands of dollars
and hours and hours
if she would commit to this
i would love for you and her
i would love for you to say hey you know
what for the last five years i've given
you a lot of information
and the one thing i don't do enough of
is just hug my baby girl
would you
give me a 30 second hug in the morning
and a 30 second hug in the evening just
every day
and mom wants it on this too
and she'd roll her eyes and just say i
just want to go back to my baby girl and
i know we can't go back to be in middle
school but you're about to go to college
and in it can we just start hugging and
i'm going to commit
if you want some info from me
you know that i'm here for you and you
know i'm your dad i love talking
right but what i really want to start
doing is
um
i want my baby girl back
and um i'm gonna quit lecturing you i'm
gonna quit i'm arguing with you i'm
gonna quit trying to give you another
article and another thing
i want a 30 second hug with you every
day
um in the morning and i want 30 second
hug and eat and she may say it dad i
can't do that and if that's the case
great say me and your mom are gonna do
30 second hugs every day
and because here's what's happened this
has affected your marriage too i know it
has because you have an idea on how to
do it mom has an idea and it's causing
fractures all over the place and that
tension feeds this spinning cycle right
it just turns into a cyclone
and so
i want you and your you and your wife
to
drop your shoulders i want you all to
start hugging each other 30 seconds a
day
if you're able to write your daughter a
just a quick note go to walgreens or go
wherever and buy a stack of cards and
just write her a note every morning that
just says
i'm the luckiest dad in the world that i
got picked to be your dad
love that that's it
that's it i love you right and what
we're trying to do now over over the
next year is we're going to try to solve
for a relationship
hey we just go for all of us going to go
for a walk after dinner i promise we
won't talk about covid politics or ocd
we're just gonna go for a walk in fact
you can wear your headphones if you wear
your headphones though you gotta hold
mom's hand that's the rule but we're
just gonna go
for a walk together and here's what
we're doing we're just
slowly teaching the amygdala that we're
okay
we're safe
and that sounds so ridiculous and so
cheesy and so oh my gosh what are you
doing dude
is she still gonna need medicine
probably
at least for a season does she still
need to see a counselor yes no question
but
what she really needs is to solve for
safe
to solve a relationship
and that's gonna start with you sitting
down saying dude i've given you enough
information to last us a lifetime let's
i'm done with it okay if you need if you
want me to answer questions specific
brain chemistry come ask me you know i
love talking about that stuff and i
still want to talk about baseball games
with you whatever
i just won't be dead
and i love you and i hurt with you you
know that i know that
let's get back to this
and then if she'll include you in
concerts she'll include you or you can
include her in concerts or whatever
things you all like to do baseball games
whatever
invite her to those things we're solving
for
relationship and
i'm about 99 sure that you and your wife
need to go see a marriage counselor too
brad
five years of dealing with this inside
your house is hard on any marriage at
all
any marriage in the world and
that tension fuels the house and so you
guys go work on you make sure your
marriage is strong that you all are good
and give that your daughter something
firm and concrete to anchor into
you're a good dad man you are
you're a good dad
your daughter's struggling she needs
medical intervention she needs
relational intervention
and she just needs her old man to say i
love you come give me a hug
let's start with some skin on skin
contact let's start with some hugs let's
start with some walks let's start with
some conversations that have nothing to
do with these other things
let's start with some experiences
together
let's start with y'all play video games
i don't care whatever it is
let's let the professionals do the
professional stuff
and let her get her dad back and my gut
tells me my gut tells me
that over the arc of several months over
the arc of a year those alarms will
slowly start turning down her brain will
start going
we're safe
we're safe
you're a good man
but yes if if medication's on the table
i i think you may be there okay sit down
with your doctor and start from the
lowest dose and work up is always my
recommendation
thank you so so so so much for that call
here we're going to take one more quick
break we'll be right back from the
doctor john's show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right as we wrap up today's show so
glad you all are here and those are a
couple of hard hard calls today um
they're hard because there's not just a
simple easy resolution
hard because people have to do
different things
different
things those are tough man solving for
relationships well that's so hard so
hard cause i just wanna ah i wanna tell
you something
all right so we wrap up today's show man
this is the the third in the trifecta
right on the back end of their
self-titled album
third eye blind it's the og when when
was this album out
97 97 150 years ago
kelly i hope you're feeling better
i know you don't feel good and i just
looked up
you don't like you feel good no a little
head cold i'm fine i don't like it when
you say 97 was 150 years ago though
since that's when i graduated from
college
[Laughter]
so i was feeling better but not so much
anymore whoa
but back then though they had like those
uh
they had people that would take your
horse and like
like they would take your horse and move
on for your own safety put in your
stables for you though right
and so the third eye blind album was
released on 78 like the old thick
records oh yeah yeah i hate you both
exactly it was only it was only done
live they had no recording devices
played it on my phonograph that's
exactly right that's cool we just had a
choir come over and sing in the front
yard for us because that's all we had
i'm sorry that you're
i'm sorry that you're old kelly all
right off the self-titled album 1997
third eye blind the song is god of wine
and it goes like this
every thought that i repent there's
another chip you haven't spent and
you're cashing them all in
where do we get clean again
can we get clean again
and i walk home alone with you and the
mood you're born into sometimes laura
you let me in
i take it on the chin and i can't get
clean again
i want to know can we get clean again
the god of wine comes crashing through
the headlights of a car that took you
further than you thought you'd ever want
to go
we can't get back again
can't get back again
i think you can
jenkins i think you can get back right
here on the dr john alone